ela se chama Jev da Typesafe AI
o fundador
ex-pesquisador da OpenAI
se diz ser
co-criador do chatgpt
o Jev não conversa
ele só decide
imagina
um
jogo onde o teu código precisa decidir
se tu vai ter que atirar
se tu vai ter que desviar ou abrir uma porta
se tu pergunta isso pra uma llm
ela vai te mandar um textão
e o teu código vai precisar achar a decisão
no meio dele
e é uma coisa que é lenta e que é caro
e ainda tem outro problema
quando a llm
inventa
um
valor que nem existe
ou ainda quebra o formato de saída
então é pra isso que tem
o structured output
e o Jev
ele pula essa etapa
então tu passa pra ele o estado do jogo
as opções que ele tem
e ele te retorna
o resultado com a decisão e a probabilidade
por exemplo
ele te retorna a saída
atirar com 92%
e mais nada de texto
segundo a empresa
ele é de 40 a 200 vezes mais rápido
é por isso que dá pra tu decidir
dez vezes por segundo no DOOM
por sete dólares a hora apenas
e não é só jogo pra quem programa
ele é como se fosse um IF inteligente
então pra classificar um ticket de suporte por exemplo
ou tu poder
decidir se uma resposta
precisa de um modelo melhor
ou ainda escolher
qual botão clicar
então o código continua sendo o teu
tu define as opções
e tu decide o que tu vai fazer
com aqueles 92%
que foi retornado do modelo
mas calma
a empresa diz que o Jev ele não alucina
isso quer dizer
que ele nunca vai inventar uma opção
fora daquela lista que tu definiu
como também nunca vai quebrar o formato de saída
mas não quer dizer que ele sempre vai acertar
porque ele pode mandar tu atirar na hora errada
por exemplo
e até agora
não tem paper público
todos os testes
ele foram realizados pela própria empresa
e aí, qual decisão do teu software tu passaria pra uma IA
que responde quase que instantaneamente
me conta aqui nos comentários
e não sabe escrever uma frase
Essa inteligência artificial joga DOOM em tempo real